上個月我們檢過諾貝爾經濟學獎得主Doron Asimoglu的訪談,
他說決定AI往哪走的是一小群讀同樣科幻小說的人,
這一場是9月20號上架的,
他拿美國跟中國來比,
主持人指出他談自由民主的新書完全沒寫中國。
主持人接著引了一個說法
西方過去150年的好日子
靠的是技術跟經濟上領先全世界
現在這個領先沒了
這是絕對的
但在某種意義上
我認為
一個 liberal democratic government
會有更好的機會
重新建立
那種技術主義
我們為什麼失去
技術主義
首先
中國在某些政策上
支持了它的製造基地
它的經濟
他們所有的信用
但是很多的
也是自負的
所有的西方政府
都一同解決了
他們的貿易保障
讓中國的製造
很便宜的生產品
甚至是資產品
來淹沒市場
和毀壞他們的企業
在AI和技術上
我們將所有資源
放進AGI
和這些非常複雜
非常大的基礎模式
作為結果
你經常聽到
美國在AI上
有一個領導
在中國
我們有一個領導
在大語言模式上
大約6到16個月
in large language models
but if you look at every aspect of
every other aspect of tech
China is doing very well
they are ahead of the United States
and the UK and most of Europe
all of Europe
in terms of integrating robotics and AI
into the production process
they are ahead of getting AI
and they have tremendous
they have made tremendous investment
in two things that are really critical
一個是生產階級,
他們有一個巨大的生產階級,
這創造了許多學習機會,
許多機會對AI和技術的使用,
以增加生產能力的方式。
他們有一個非常有能力和大量的工程師,
這很重要,
因為它們能夠將AI融入每個生產過程中的每個部分。
所以,這些都是我們也能做到的事情。
美國並沒有投資在工程。
Asimoglu分析過蘇聯
蘇聯的經濟一度表現不錯
後來垮掉
他認為是因為體制做不到創造性破壞
主持人拿中國反問他
我認為如果你看到創造破壞
作為一種中心化的過程
使新的想法出現
以及挑戰既存在的想法
或商務實施或策略
中國不太好
仍然有很多這種過程的管理
中國非常好地發展
developing existing technological lines
and lines of business
extremely competently
so if you see
look at their AI industry for instance
you see that
what they have done with deep seek
and the Kimi models etc
is an engineering marvel
they have just perfected
how you can use existing methods
in a cost effective way
perhaps they've used
some of the distilling techniques
in order to reverse engineer
一些更豐富的模型的重量
但他們真的在一個便宜和優秀的方式上做了這些
你看到他們的製造基地
就像是一部Marvel 2的設計
每個部分都在嘗試調整
所以這就是為什麼有些公司
比如BYD Foxconn
是臺灣的公司
但是在中國有很大的活動
或是Huawei
因為他們是大型公司
So the new blood coming in
and challenge the system
is still not so active
and whether it's going to be
down the line
still remains to be seen
China is still not at the level of
Western European and British
or American GDP per capita
but it's approaching it fast
訪談最後
主持人問他
英國的生產力
從2008年到現在
幾乎沒有成長
該怎麼辦
他先講了幾個原因
砸解脫歐中國的競爭
工作主義,那是美國未來的目標。
安迪·貝爾南,一個他的網友正在聽話。
Pro worker AI, how do we do that?
我認為,首先,我們必須要用傳統設計。
There are so many low hanging fruit
電子工程師
Not trying to mimic human talent
to expand their expertise
to enable them to do new things
to do things that are more creative
more innovative
we need more innovation
in the UK
in the world
because of climate change
because of aging
because of changing global balances
and innovation
I think in the foreseeable future
is going to remain an activity
in which we need human talent
so the question is
how can we give better tools
for that human talent
yeah this is something again
comes across really in the book
你討論了很多關於自動技術
but it's not about replacing people
it's about augmenting them
and really trying to maximize
that boost in productivity
我們已經看不見了
100%
這是AGI的目標
AGI的目標是
基本上
讓人們認識到
AI能做的最好和最不可能的事情
是讓人們變得更好
讓人們變得更好
最後一個問題
為什麼那麼多人
為此而落下
這是 Washington的歷史
最令人印象深刻的努力
還是有更深刻的事情
我覺得
部分是歷史
with Microsoft, Google, Oracle
becoming giants
And some of it is science fiction
實際上
from its inception
這是科學的一種
and then take over and threaten humans
We've imagined that
我們在1950年代
照S-Moglu的說法
美國壓在AGI
只換到大模型上一點領先
工廠裡的AI已經輸給中國
他要英國別跟著美國
讓AI去幫護理師
電工跟老師
原影片77分鐘
大部分在談他的新書
他也講到
AI公司老闆一談人類滅絕
薪水跟不平等的討論
就被蓋過去
原影片連結在說明欄
有興趣可以去聽更多